Hello,
we're all did SAROJ and welcome to this
live stream of my new 100 k a youtube
channel livestream.
I'm very excited for this.
Thank you guys for a hundred
k subscribers. By the way.
I am very happy and we are the fastest
growing artificial intelligence community
in the world.
Okay,
so today we are going to be talking
about Disco Ganz and the name is pretty
interesting, right? But it has
nothing to do with disco balls. But Q,
the disco mute. No, I'm just kidding.
No, we're not going to do that.
We're going to be
building a model that is,
that consists of six
different neural networks now.
So it sounds complicated and it is,
but,
but it's going to be really easy because
I'm building a very bare bones version
of it and it's going to be in tenser flow.
Okay? And you're, you might be asking,
why should we be doing this?
Saroj what is the point of this?
I see purses and I see shoes.
Uh, now here's, here's,
here's the cool thing about
this. Okay. Using Disco Gan,
this is a new type of
generative adversarial network.
I mean there's paper literally just
came out last month, like last month.
And it's very exciting because I was
just going over this paper and trying to
make sure that I understood all the
details before I did this stream.
And now I've got a good, uh,
I've, I've dropped it pretty well.
So I'm excited to share
with you what I've learned.
So this paper came out not
last month but two months ago,
but it was called learning to discover
cross domain relations with generative
adversarial networks. Okay. And I'm
going to answer questions in a second.
Let me just explain this first. But
the, the, the idea behind the paper was,
so the word disco comes from discover,
so, right. It's like disco discover,
cross the main relations. So the idea
was we have two different image datasets.
One of them is let's say purses
and the other one is a set of,
so let's say shoes.
And what we can do using disco Gan is we
can generate images from one dataset in
the style of another.
So here you see exactly what it can do.
Like here's two sets of examples.
The first set of examples is
saying in a fully trained district,
this Gauguin on these two datasets,
purses and shoes, given some novel purse,
you can say,
generate this purse in the style,
generate a shoe in the style
of this purse. Right? So this,
this is really interesting, right?
So it's style transfer essentially,
but it's not like the style
transfer that we've seen before.
So recall that we've, we've talked
about style transfer before. Uh,
but it was more like, you
know, Mona Lisa, uh, you know,
starry nights style transfer.
The style transfer that we did
before was basic. Okay. Basic Aif.
It was essentially like an, like an
Instagram image filter where we just have,
if we consider two
images to be to, uh, uh,
matrices of pixel values,
and of course, you know,
it's gotta be bad results, but you
know what I'm talking about, right?
We have a starry night picture and then
we have some image and we just overlaid
that style onto that other picture, like
Van Gogh or whatever it is. And that's,
that was a naive approach, right?
We, why is it naive? Why is it naive?
Because we're not, we're not focusing on
some subject. We're not saying like it.
The machine doesn't actually know like
this exact Mona Lisa is all we want to
transfer this style too. Let's
just transfer everything, right?
So what this Gauguin does, it is, it is,
it's like smart or style transfer,
right?
Because what it's generating isn't like
a purse and it's kind of like molded
into a shoe. No, it's an actual, it's
an actual shoe. It looks like a shoe.
It, it looks like it would be something
that just wasn't generated. Right.
It looks very realistic.
Like a style in and of itself.
And Gans are really good at this.
They're really good at this.
Like insanely good. This is
a cycle again, video, right?
Notice how we've, we've transferred
the style of a zebra to a horse,
but it's not like we're making
everything black and white.
We're just making the horse black
and white, which is incredible.
It's just incredible. This technology is
incredible and it's just moving so fast.
So I'm really excited to talk about this.
And what I found is that it's
actually very intuitive to,
to understand, okay. Uh, so we,
let's, and here's the other thing.
So we humans, we do this very well, right?
Cross domain relations. If I have a,
you know,
if I've got a black suit,
I know that what goes well with it,
the cross domain, the domain of suits,
what's the cross domain relation?
What's the other domain that's related
to this domain? I could say, you know,
some dope like leather boots would go
well with it or something like, um,
we're just able to do it well
or like Burger and fries,
like this type of Burger.
It goes well with this hyper fries,
but can machines do it?
And the answer is yes they can because
we are able to make them do it.
So we can frame it as a conditional
image generation problem, right?
Given one image purse con generate a
new new image condition on a different
dataset. And that would be like
shoes, right? So we've done,
we've talked about conditional
probability distribution before, right?
Probability of x, given why rather
than the probability of x alone.
So that's essentially what it is.
That's one way of for us to frame it.
And in terms of use cases, games, design,
science,
engineering,
anytime you want any kind of visual
feedback of what you're thinking,
just imagine,
just imagine a a text or
voice interface or you say,
I want to take this three d model that
I have is cad model and I want to apply
all of these features to it and an
a disco Gan that's been generally,
that's been trained on all of these
different datasets. We'll be able to say,
okay, here it is. Just like that because
it's already been trained, right? So the,
the actual generation
process doesn't take forever.
It's a training process
that takes forever.
So there's a lot of possibilities
for pretty much any a science,
engineering or art especially,
uh,
any field where there is some kind
of creation or discovery involved.
Perfect for it. And Games of course.
Well, any kind of virtual world,
there is so much possibility. Think,
think beyond the purse and the shoe. Okay.
That's just the example that we're
using. Think big. Okay. Think big.
Okay. And that, that is,
that is where the money is.
That's where the opportunity is.
That's where, that's where it's,
that's where it's, that's where it's at.
That's what I would be doing if I was, um,
doing, you know, a startup or whatever.
I would be looking at ways of taking
this technology and applying it to real
world problems that people encounter.
Okay. So that's the high level.
So let me answer two questions and
then we'll get started with the code.
Okay. So the first, uh,
question that is going to,
I'm going to answer once I
pull up my question window is,
uh,
just logging in.
This is pretty cool. Uh, let
me, let me make this bigger.
The fun definitely needs to be bigger,
but we no longer support
this version of your browser.
That's what happens when
it happens. Okay. So we've
got 324 people watching.
Let me see who in the room.
Why do you use particularly tensorflow?
That's a great question.
Why do you use tensorflow?
So the reason I use tensorflow and
up, and you're right because the, the,
the authors of the paper
did this in Pi Torch.
Pi Torch is getting really
cool. It's getting really, uh,
used by a lot of cool people.
Remember that Pi Torch in five
minutes video that I just made,
Yann Macun shared that on Facebook and
it got like a Ha. I was like, oh my God,
y'all look good dude. That guy
is so cool. Anyway, okay. Um,
Geez status.
So yeah.
So why don't I do an intention flow
because this course is intensive low and I
didn't want to just, you know, drop Pi
Torch on you guys. All of a sudden we got,
we've got to stick to tensorflow for now,
but I promise you Pi Torch is coming.
Tensorflow is great. Okay. It's not,
it's not a bad, it's not a bad framework.
It's just,
you know,
it's what we're used to and we want to
focus on the algorithms right now instead
of syntax. So that's what I'm
going to keep using tensorflow.
Let me answer one more question and then
we'll get started with the code. Uh,
the other question is,
the other question is how do you select,
oh no,
this is a great question. What is the
best way in resource to learn algorithms?
What is the best systematic way to
learn machine learning? Best Resource.
I know it's your videos and I'm
already following them. So, okay,
those are two separate questions.
The first algorithms is the best way.
So I have a great video on this.
It's called how to succeed
in any programming interview.
I give you a great study guide to get
your data structures and algorithms skills
on point. So check that out. In terms
of machine learning, guests, my videos,
this playlist, I have, you
know, several courses on it.
You Udacity has several great machine
learning courses. Uh, but yeah,
that's what I would say. You
Udacity, my courses, you know,
just together great resources and if you
want really in depth and you have the
time and you've got the, you've
got the motivation to not to, to,
to learn without needing it to
be entertained whatsoever. Uh,
which I need to be entertained. I just
entertain myself with music and stuff. Uh,
then probably the deep learning book,
uh,
by Ian Goodfellow and
Yoshua Bengio. Okay. Uh,
but more than that, you know,
I, I'm beginning to, you know,
it's, it's something that I believed
I believed in my head for a while,
but I've never actually said it.
Um, because it's so, uh, radical,
but textbooks are just no stop,
stop reading textbooks.
It's not about the textbooks we
live in the age of, uh, you know,
the Internet and Twitter and all
this stuff. We don't need to,
we don't have to have, we don't
have, we don't need to read books.
Book should read themselves to us.
Right? Right. We need an easier way up.
It's just data and algorithms,
right.
Learning is just a process of data and
algorithms and we need to get it into our
head and what's a great medium for that
video? Uh, and all sorts of, um, you know,
very condensed, you know, stuff. Anyway,
okay, let's get started with this.
I'm going to talk about most of the code
and I'm going to code the parts that
really matter. Okay. So
the first part is, okay,
the first part of this is going to
be us defining our dependencies.
Let me make sure the text is big enough.
Big like a boughs big, like a boss. Okay.
Oh there's, there's uh, one
more thing I want to talk about.
So how should we structure
this architecture?
Let's do a thought exercise
for a second, right? We want,
we have to image data sets.
Okay.
We have to image data sets and we want
to generate an image in the style of
another. Okay, so conditional
image generation. Well,
one naive way we can think about this is
an encoder decoder architecture, right?
So we have some image and then we
encode it into a Lenten space, right?
We have some latent space in
coding and then we decode it again.
But when we decode it,
we keep that light and space
and we condition it on the
other image data set so
that that image is the one that's decoded
is exactly like a reconstruction of
the original,
but it's conditioned on the other dataset.
That's a naive way of doing it because
what that would do is like the original
style transfer paper, it would, it
would just make everything styled,
but it wouldn't be that you wouldn't be
that specific transfer that we're doing
right now. So that's, that's
the naive way. It's like a
camera filter on Instagram.
A better way is what if we had two
encoder decoders write one for each image
data set and to both
conditioned on each other,
that would be good and that it
would make it backwards compatible.
But it's still naive,
backwards compatible in that we could
generate us chew in the style of a purse
and a person that's stylish shoe,
but the dope boy of doing this,
and that's the one that we're going to
do is doing to encoder decoders in an
adversarial Tom context.
Let me talk about what this looks like,
but before we show,
I show you the architecture.
Let's define our dependencies
and our datasets. Okay.
So those are some questions
that I wanted to answer. Uh,
and I'll answer questions later.
But let's start off with this.
So we first bridge the gap between
Python two and three with the future,
which is totally necessary
a lot of the time. Okay.
Is that for things like the
print function, whatever.
And then we're going to use
[inaudible] for saving files.
And then num Pi for matrix math map plot
live is our Handy Dandy visualization
library for data. We're using
tensorflow for machine learning and uh,
this is a custom class. These two are
custom classes for generating data,
using what's called a
golf Sian mixture model,
which is a really cool idea that I haven't
talked about in this course and I'm
excited to talk about that. Uh, and then
we have a progress bar for, for training.
And then, uh, we're also going
to be using the TF slim library,
which I haven't also used before,
but don't worry, it's just,
it's just tension flow. It just
tentraflow neatly wrapped, neatly wrapped,
similar to Carrie Ross. I'll talk about
the differences. And then we have our, uh,
this distributions class that's going
to represent batches of statistical
distributions. Uh, that's going to help
us generate our data. And then lastly, uh,
this graph replace a method
which is going to let a function,
which is going to let us,
uh,
to regenerate a network,
uh, with replaced 10 stores.
And I'll talk about why that's
that. That is okay. If, so,
those are our dependencies and let's start
defining our hyper parameters, right?
So what are our hyper parameters will
be four. We define our hyper parameters.
We need to know how many networks
we're going to use, right?
We're gonna use a one, two, three,
four, five, six, six different networks.
This is what our architecture looks like
right here and move out of the way just
like that. So this is what our
architecture looks like. Okay?
It's kind of confusing if you,
if it's your first glance.
So like I've been looking at those for
a while. It's actually not confusing.
So here's how it works.
We have four generators.
Each of these boxes is a generator.
This one, this one, this one, this one.
And then we have two discriminators
discriminator, one discriminator too.
Okay. And then what is going on
here? Well, each of these generators,
let's just look at these two on top
of your right, like right here. Okay,
this one is an encoder
and this one is a decoder.
We can just think of it that way.
That's,
that's how we're framing
these generators. Okay? Okay.
So it's an encoder and a decoder.
And it's the same for this one.
It's an encoder and a decoder.
And then we have two discriminators.
So these generators are both
encoders and decoders. Okay?
So what am I talking about here? So we'll
give it an image. Let's say it's this,
uh, this blonde woman, and
then we will encode it and it,
so what do I mean by encoding? So why
don't we normally think about encoding.
We're thinking about taking some image
and converting it into a latent space.
So rights and representation
of that image.
And so that's exactly
what we're doing here. Uh,
but we are a conditioning
it when we encode it on the,
uh, separate, the other image data sets.
So let's say we had the blonde woman,
but then the other image data
set was dark haired women.
So this would be a mix
of the two, right? What,
what Incode is going to be a mix of
the two. And then when we decode,
we're taking that conditioned,
uh,
image that's generated and we're
reconstructing the original.
We're trying to best
reconstruct the original.
And what happens here is then we can
measure the loss between the reconstructed
image and the original image and we'll
use that loss and feed that to the
discriminator. So the same thing is
happening for this encoder decoder para,
but it's the opposite. So we,
so for this one, it's image.
Let's say it's like data set one,
two Dataset to, for this one,
it's from data set to data set one as
in instead of generate a shoe from the
purse, get generate a
purse from a shoe. So it's,
so it's like the backwards version of it.
It's like vice versa, you know, like the,
the opposite. We do the same exact
thing, but, but the opposite,
what this does and the reason we have
this is so that we can do it both ways.
We can generate images in both,
uh, crossed up in both domains.
Just as well. And we feed both of those
losses to our discriminators. Okay.
So we have two separate
discriminators for each of them.
So these are both generative networks.
So you might be thinking,
wait a second generators,
they're just,
they're just going to be
continuously upsampling. Right?
Well, when we decode your,
you're normally thinking about doing the
opposite of what you just did before.
So for an encoder decoder with, uh,
with two convolutional networks,
you would think that for encoding
with convolutional nets, you're,
you're downsampling. And then for
the Di Carter, you're upsampling,
but in this case, because
they're both generators, we're
essentially continuously,
uh, upsampling. So that is weird.
Generating an image, right?
And then we're going to continue, we're
going to generate again from that image.
So it's just like one big huge generator
pair, just continuously generating. Okay.
Uh, and so that's, that's
how that, that's how that is.
And we can use different things.
We can use convolutional nets
for images and we can use, uh,
all sorts of things like that.
So
that is that.
And now what I want to do is I want to
talk about the data generation part.
Okay?
So let's get to the data generation part.
Okay.
So for the data generation part,
I'm going to talk about how we're going to
do this. Okay. So the first step is, oh,
the hyper parameters. So
those are our models, right?
So these are our hyper parameters
for those models. The first,
and I'm going to answer
questions in five minutes.
So the first set of hyper parameters,
standard hyper parameters,
and they apply to our, uh, uh,
generators and or discriminators.
These are general use cases,
right?
Because we're going to have some weight
sharing happening between these models.
Some of these, some of these models like
the two first generators share weights.
And what this does is it,
it's just a lot.
It's just improved across the main
generation. So then we have discriminator,
you know, uh, hyper parameters and
then generate our hyper parameters.
And then I have this inference network.
So the reason we call it an inference
network, it's just a generator.
It's just the generator. But we're calling
it an inference network just for like,
uh,
having that difference. So
we don't get confused, right?
So we can just call it generator again,
but we want to call it something different
just so we don't get super confused
because there are a lot of terms,
right? Encoder, decoder, generator,
adversary discriminator. So there's
like a lot of terms a, but it's two g,
two generator pairs, like January janitor,
January, January two. Discriminators.
That's it.
Okay.
So these are our hyper parameters and
these are the hyper parameters that were
implemented in the original
paper. Okay. So then, uh,
the next step is first who
save our results to our folder,
our disco again folder whenever,
whenever we're done.
So we'll create a directory for that.
Okay.
So then how are we going to generate this
data? Are we going to use images? No,
we're going to use a more
simple dataset because it's, uh,
and I'll show you the results from
the image generation and, and stuff.
But for this, you know, just to, to
get, uh, grokking of the architecture,
we're going to do some really simple
datasets and that's what we're going to
generate it. Okay. Let me show you
what it looks like when we generate it,
but we're going to use something called
a golf Sian mixture model to generate
this data. Okay. So when,
what we're going to do is to,
is we're going to generate data using a
golf Sian mixture model. Okay. And these,
there are two data sets,
right? There are two datasets.
There's the Red Dataset and
there's the green dataset.
And we want to generate that using
gosh, in mixture model. So what is this,
what is a golf swing mixture model?
Well, recall that Gosselin is a,
is the bell curve, right? It's a, it's,
it's a distribution between two uh,
numbers.
It's a distribution in
two and an interval pair.
A mixture model uses several golf scions.
Okay.
He uses several golf seems to generate
data and some of that data might be, uh,
it uses those distributions,
settled distributions to generate data.
And why do we use Garcia mixture
models? Uh, and so like this,
this data right here,
it was generated using a handoff Sian
mixture model and we saved it from a
previous training session. This is
what our data is that will look like.
And then what we want to do is we can
consider these two different domains and
we want to find the intersection.
So whenever we're going to generate
new images that are intersected, uh,
between these two domains,
so where would they be?
They would end up being like right here.
So here's what it would look like.
Once we're done with this test Dataset,
it will look like this.
Let me just pull up this pdf.
You see these red values,
he's red values. That's what we're going
to generate. And what this shows is it,
it is a proof,
is that proof that we can generate new
images that are across domain, that is,
they apply to both
different both datasets.
And then we literally just replace the
datasets with something more interesting.
And we can do all sorts of cool things,
but let's focus on the architecture
right now. Okay. So, yeah.
So the way that's, that's how we
generate this using gosh and Mr models.
And you might be wondering,
well is there another way for us to
generate this without using, gosh,
your mixture models. Sure. You
could just use a, you know,
a golf Sian alone. But uh,
what this does is it's,
it's better for clustering.
It's better for finding relationships
between the two data points.
If we're using a mixture model,
there's already an inherent relationship
between the two data points.
And what this does is it,
it,
it gives us some ground truth from
which we can generate data from. Okay.
So this is the formula for a gosh,
you mixture model and
here's what it looks like.
We say the probability of x,
that is some data set of elements.
What,
what we're going to generate depends
on these three variables right here.
The mean, okay. The uh,
the mixing weights and then the,
the wolves.
This one Alpha, which is the, no,
so the variance,
the,
yeah,
I wrote these down. So this is going
to be the variance, the mixing, wait,
and then the, and then there's the sigma,
which is the, the density function.
That's what it is. Okay, so this,
okay, so what we say is we say,
and we're going to write
this out programmatically,
what we say is sigma notation for k were,
wereK is a number of elements in our
dataset. We first applied this alpha,
this Alpha value, which is,
which is a mixing wait, which
we can decide beforehand.
And then this end looking thing means
the golf Sian distribution. So to golf,
Sian,
probably distribution of x,
which is our data set of elements given
our mean and our variants. Okay,
what were the square of our variance?
And so we need these three values and
mean the barriers and the mixing weights
to be able to generate a data
points in this distribution. Okay?
So that's what we're going to,
we're going to do here.
But let me first answer some
questions here. Uh, okay.
Okay.
So how to determine the number of hidden
layers required for a particular deep
neural net question. Okay.
So that's a great question.
How to determine the number
of layers in a deep net.
The way we do that is by looking at what
has been done before in papers and then
reimplementing that because hyper
parameter optimization is still a field of
discovery.
We need more algorithms to learn how
to learn hyper parameters, right?
One way to do this manually and since
you just have the same model and each
model has a different set
of hyper parameters and
then we run them on the same
dataset and see which one works best,
right? In parallel distributed training,
right?
And then see which one works best.
And that's essentially what
a lot of machine learning is.
It's just like different people trying
out different sense of hyper parameters.
And there's not like one true way of
doing it, right? It's use case dependent.
And I think it definitely
needs to be better,
right?
It needs to be more efficient.
It needs to be something that we learn to
learn. And that's actually, you know, um,
my video is coming out on this, so
it's literally in a few days, uh,
which is really cool.
And then two more questions.
Uh,
looks like I lost my connection
here. Uh, so it's taking a well,
but I see it,
these two older questions.
So can we use tensorflow for
you? Can't. Absolutely. I mean,
a lot of great researchers use
tensorflow for research and it's, uh,
it's been used a lot, but, but although
Pi Torch has been used a lot more now for,
for, for research by serious
researchers. So. Cool.
So that's it for the questions.
Let me get back to the code. Okay.
So for the GAA Sian mixture model,
um, we're going to, we're still,
we're still good, right guys?
Where's the lighting hunger? Great.
So let's go ahead and do this. So the
first step is for us to generate our, uh,
intervals,
right?
Defining our intervals that we're going
to generate this gossipy mixture model
from.
So each of these sets of intervals is a,
is we can consider them components,
right? We call them components, right?
So from zero to zero,
from two to two,
from negative one to negative one
from one tonight and one, right?
So when we define that using the
lambda or anonymous function, uh,
given x. So we say we want to create a
num, py, IRA from these intervals. Okay.
And then we're going to store that
in means. So that's our set of means.
We convert that to a list and it's just a,
and why do we convert it to a list?
Because we can perform a lot of
interesting operations with the list.
The list is a great data type in, in
python. And then we say, well, here's the,
here's our standard deviation that
we defined. We want it to be point,
0.1 and then our variances or
we're going to say, so the,
so the eye function of num Pi
returns an identity matrix,
which is a two d array with, with, uh,
one's on the diagonal and
an zero everywhere else.
And so why do we need that identity?
Major CS are necessary to
generate variances, variances.
So we take the identity matrix and we
multiply it by the standard deviation for
every value in the means.
So for all of those components,
and that's going to give us our, our
variances, right? Then we're going to,
we're going to use our PR,
we're going to generate our prior,
which is this value right up here,
which is our prior beliefs.
So when it comes to probability theory,
we have a prior,
which is your belief before
you come into a problem.
So before you examine a problem,
it's a Bayesian approach, right?
Bayesians believe in priors, frequent
his stone. It's a huge debate.
It's an ongoing debate. So
it's a holy war. Uh, but yes,
I, I followed the Bayesean
Basie and logic.
Okay.
So for priors we're going to say one
divided by the means for all of the means
is going to give us our
prior value. Okay. Uh,
and so then we're going to use those
values that we just computed to generate
our, generate our golf
Sian mixture model. Okay.
And then once we have our
golf Sian mixture model,
we're going to sample from it.
Okay. So we've defined what
this model looks like, this,
this architecture and this,
this,
this structure from which we
can now generate data from.
We've defined our parameters for it
and we can generate data from it.
And so this is our helper function to do
that. And we'll get to our dataset. Okay.
And then we will save the data set and I,
and which I visualize and I showed you
guys and then we're going to plot it
showed you guys, and then we're going
to store the samples and the labels.
So this is interesting. So is
we have samples, the labels, uh,
but we're not going to use the samples,
they're just there. So we have just,
and so we can think of this
as x and y points, right?
The samples or the x points and the, and
the labels or the y points. Okay. Uh,
and so we'll do that twice
for two different datasets.
We have one data set that we call x and
we had the other that we call Z, right?
Two different datasets.
And so we all have both of the datasets.
We just repeat the process twice and
then we can sample from them. Right?
So we have eventually we'll take both a
non pyre raise for both sets of data and
we'll have our x Dataset
Nrz did. I said, okay,
so that's our data and now we
can start defining our networks,
our model. Okay, so they, they
looked at this problem, right?
And so they were considering like
what type of model should we use?
And we had this,
we just had this interesting thought
exercise earlier on in this live stream
where I talked about,
well should we use an encoder decoder?
Should we use to in Cody cutters,
should we use to encoder decoder
is within our adversarial approach.
They had the same thought process,
right?
And so this happens a lot in
research where we are like thinking,
well what if this would be the way I
know it would if this would be the way,
well let's just try out all the
ways and see what works best.
That's exactly what they did. So they,
so they tried out one very simple model,
another model,
and then they came to this model that
we're going to hit them it and they found
that this far outperformed the other
models and this is just a thing in machine
learning and deep learning where it seems
like the more complexity we add to a
model, the better the
results are. Generally,
obviously there are going to be anomalies,
no pun intended when it
comes to anomaly detection,
but they're going to be an old lease.
But generally the more complexity we add,
the more we chain these models together,
the more interesting the results are.
Wavenet is a great example,
a pixel RNN pixel,
CNN and a path net.
They're a bunch of examples,
but that's what our brain is, right? We
don't just have a convolutional network,
we have a convolutional net for our
eyes and we have a recurrent net in our
hippocampus and we have feet forward
nets happening probably in our somewhere
else, but we have all sorts of networks
that are happening, right? As we,
when we combine them,
we get an interesting result.
And when the network observes itself
and it goes through this loop of self
observation and just leave the loop
just keeps going faster and faster.
That's when we get consciousness.
But that's a whole different thing.
Godel Escher, Bach, lots of
philosophy there. Okay. So
where were we? Consciousness.
No. Yeah. Okay. This, this go
again. Just go again. Okay.
So here we are. Uh, okay. Where were we?
So this is another image that they had
in the paper where they said, okay,
we have our, our datasets. And so
let's talk about the failure cases,
what we don't want. So if we look
here at this and make this bigger,
I know I answer questions.
I know I haven't enhanced
your questions in a while.
Uh,
so,
okay.
So sometimes
sometimes the internet doesn't
work, so that's okay. So where was,
what we don't want is we
don't want the images,
the same image to generate a dif,
different images.
We want us a straight
image to image mapping.
What do I mean by that? Something that
is predictable. So we know that, uh,
that there is no failure case where we
give it to different types of images and
it will generate the same image, even
though these are two different images,
right?
We want variety,
we want novel images to be generated no
matter what kind of image we give it,
right? We don't want the same mapping.
So those are failure cases that it's,
and it's a good practice to think about.
Before we were building models,
what are possible failure cases? What,
what do we don't want to happen? Okay?
And it's good to just as a thought
exercise to map those out to, to,
to put those down on paper. Okay? So
that's what that is.
And so now what we're gonna do is we're
going to define these networks, okay?
So let's define these networks. So
remember, we have six networks, okay?
And the way that I'm going to define
these is we're going to use tensorflow
slim. Now, this is just beautiful, right?
So I've never actually used tensorflow
slim in a, in a, in a video before,
but it's, it's actually, you know,
it's a, it's a very beautiful, uh,
a library of tensorflow because,
because, uh, there are,
it's very compact and dense.
So let me, let me answer two questions
before start starting to build this.
Uh, let's see. One great question is
how can we make money with this?
Okay. I mean, yeah, there's,
there's a lot of potential here.
What are some problems where people
right now need to visualize something but
they, they can't, they, it takes a lot of
effort. The barrier to entry is very high.
How can you reduce the barrier to entry
for say, designing or visualization?
Cad engineers are very well paid experts
and there are very few of them and it
takes a lot of time and energy and skill
and practice to be able to generate
images with cad.
What if you use a generative adversarial
network to let anyone generate images
with a text query? Okay. With
a simple description, boom,
billion dollar idea,
one more billion dollar idea.
What can I think of on the spot here?
When it comes to a special effects
of know. Here's, here's a great one.
When it comes to video effects,
when it comes to after effects
or Photoshop or an editor,
an editing program, it's
a bunch of effects, right?
But none of them really use
generative adversarial networks.
Imagine the effects that
you could create with this.
It would blow whatever they
have that's like, you know,
some kind of linear combination
under the hood, out of the water.
You would just dazzle people. Okay? So
that's where we are right now. Okay.
So anyway,
yeah,
hairstyle transfers. Not happening today.
I know, but uh, eventually it will happen.
By the way, if you want to,
here's, here's what it is.
A Dye your hair with
the silver stripe here,
send me the picture on Twitter.
I'll retweet it. Okay. Just do it.
It's going to be dope.
Uh, cool. So where are we?
Everything about me is open source,
guys, my hair, all about everything.
It's all open source. Take, take what
you need, take what you need. Okay,
so the first thing is the generator.
So we have two generators here.
And remember we're calling one generator
and we're calling one inference network
just for the, just for a difference.
We could call a generator too,
but they're both generators. Okay? So in
this case, we don't have images, right?
We don't have images. So we're not
going to use convolutional blocks.
We're going to use fully connected layers
because these are just numbers, right?
This is, these are just
numbers who they are. This is,
this is a set of feedforward networks.
What they set a fully connected layers.
Okay? So, uh, how many layers do we want?
What we define that right
here with number of layers.
So the great thing about tensorflow slim
is that we can define a set of layers
by one line of code. What do I mean
by that? We can say slim dot repeat.
So given some data set z and then the
parameters for what we want the network to
look like, we can say, okay, so
z equals h. Okay? So h is now,
it's our data stored in h. So we'll
say slimmed RRP, take the Dataset,
take the data that we input,
the input data,
and then we want this many
number of layers type of lyric,
fully connected with this
many hidden, uh, nodes.
And then this is the activation function.
We want to apply to it.
Relu and it does that, that number of
times. And then we had at the very end,
one last fully connected layer and
that's returned the output of that.
And that is our prediction would,
in this case, our generation,
what we've generated. And it's going to
be a set of numbers in this case, right?
Because these are numbers
that we're inputting.
And so that's the great thing
about tensorflow slim. And if that,
if that doesn't make sense,
then just like
I forgot, there's no internet.
So, so that's what that is. Okay.
So that's the first step. And uh,
we're going to do this twice, right?
So we're going to do that for our
generator and we're going to do,
that's for our inference network.
We do it twice to set the fully connected
networks and that's gonna eventually
generate our data, right? So
that's it for our generators.
And then for our discriminators, our
discriminators, we're going to use a
fully connected layers as well.
Okay.
So both of these are going to
use fully connected layers and
we're going to,
for the reason we concatenate x,
which is our hand put data with one is
to approximate the log data density.
And why do we want that? Well
we are just out putting a, uh,
we're out putting a binary value, right?
Whether it's, whether it's real or fake,
whether the image is real or fake. And in
this case real or fake is if it is, uh,
if the,
if the generated image image is uh,
from the true data distribution,
which is the original image data set,
or it's from the not true data
distribution, which is something that's
uh,
a mix of the two. So we want to
optimize for the mix of the two, right?
So we'll minimize the opposite. That's
what our discriminator does. It,
it tries to judge if something is real.
But real in this case is you can't
tell that it is a mix of the two.
It just looks like it's a,
an image of its own and it comes from
both distributions and you would think
that it comes and he thinks that
it comes from both distributions,
but it's actually a novel distribution.
I'm mixed distribution. So if it's a bad,
if it's, if our, if our model is bad,
it's going to be able to detect that
this sloppy purse looking shoe thing is
actually fake, right? It's,
it's from a novel distribution.
It's not as intertwined with the
other tooth distribution sets.
So say liberal fake,
but if it's really well generated in
that it is balanced in terms of the
distributions that it's
generated from that you can,
you can't even tell then it's
real. Okay. So that's what,
that's what we mean by real in this case.
Real versus fake. Okay. So then, uh, yeah,
they're there for the discriminator.
There are also a set of fully
connected layers are both feet forward.
And then we're going to output a TF
dot squeeze for the generated data.
And then we say the reason we're using
squeeze is because it removes the
dimensions of size one from the
shape of a, of a tensor. Uh, cool.
So that's it for our generator. Okay.
And our discriminator is plural.
Okay.
So then I could code these out,
but let me answer some questions
to see what the deal is here.
Uh, who else? We got? Q
and Q and. A. All right,
so we have some people has it for tonight.
So here's what the Q and a is.
How can you use deep learning?
How can you use deep learning for
detecting a spoofed frank fingerprint?
A spoofed fingerprint.
So you would have to have a Dataset of,
oh, interesting. That's
an interesting problem.
So it depends on who's the,
who's the spoofing that we are trying to
predict, right? If it, if it's one person,
it's very easy,
right?
Because you just have a bunch of samples
of their real fingerprint, right?
So it's a supervised learning problem, a
supervised classification problem, right?
So we have a supervised classification
problem, left one person's fingerprint,
and then you would just say,
these are all the real ones.
So you train it on the real ones
where they're labeled railroad real.
And then ideally you could,
here's what I would do.
I would take those real images and
then I'd apply some kind of, uh,
some distribution on those images so that
it would create some buried version of
them, some, you know,
so maybe even use the generative
adversarial network to generate fake but
realistic looking images of that Dataset,
but then label them fake. So then you,
you've tried at home what's real and
what's fake and given a fake one,
you could just say that that's fake.
Okay. Okay. So then two more questions.
Uh,
can I use a Gan for anime
related purposes? Yes, you can.
So literally, literally on my
Internet's not working right now,
but literally just search anime Gan
like one word and you will find a,
I swear to God or result on get hub for
this. I was actually looking at this,
but it generates animate characters using,
using the generative adversarial network.
And then one more question is, uh,
what approach should I
follow to get a job in this?
So that's a good question as well.
That's a good question as well.
So a good approach to follow if you want
to get a job in this is whether you're
in college or whether you are,
you have a full time job.
You need to find the time to learn
this stuff. So that's step one.
Find the time to learn this stuff.
So dedicate some set amount of
time every day to just study this,
whether it be papers, whether it be
code. Here's the, here's the best way,
besides consuming content, my
videos, besides consuming content,
you need to try to reimplement papers.
That's going to be really hard at first.
But eventually, like anything,
you're going to get better at it.
Whenever you keep doing,
you get better at whether it's kickboxing,
whether it's machine learning, whatever
you keep repeating, you get better at.
That's how our brain works. So just keep
looking at code, keep writing out code,
keep trying to read them and papers
and eventually before you know it,
you won't even realize it. You're
like, oh, now I'm an expert.
It happens really fast, but you have
to put in the time and the effort.
That's all you need with the Internet.
Okay.
I might freestyle at the end depending on
how I feel. Okay, cool. So back to this.
So I was going to code this,
but honestly there is a
lot like the Internet's not
working so I'm just going to
look at this and it's all good though.
So here's how it is for our
last functions and our networks,
we define the functions for our networks,
right? We've defined them there.
They're done. Now we can actually
start implementing our functions. So,
so check this out.
Okay. So check this out.
First we're going to define placeholders
for both of our data sets, right?
We have x and we have a seat.
Remember we generated both using a
Gaussian mixture model. Those are,
those are both of our data sets.
We've got a data sets,
let's feed them into our model.
That's the next step.
So now we'll define both far generators.
And remember we defined
them both respectively.
One is the generative network and
what is he? Inference. Network. Okay.
He's our incoders, right? So these are
incoders. They are, where are they?
Where are they? They are right here.
One the blue one right here,
and this yellow orange one right here.
That's what we've just defined.
Okay.
Those are our encoders in coder
generators. Okay. And then
now talk about more use cases after this
we've got both of our encoders and now
we're going to define our discriminators,
which were the two discriminators
on the side here. Okay,
so and did to generate these, we gave
it the two respective data sets, right?
Z and x and then our hype and then our
hyper parameters that we defined forehand.
Then we have our discriminators and we're
going to use data network x and then
data network Z, right? We have two
different discriminators and we'll just,
what we're going to feed it,
what we're going to do is we're going
to feed it are the outputs of our
generators, right? We wanna, we
wanna feed it the output, right?
What have we generated? I,
let's see if it's real or fake.
Let's discriminate if you're real or fake.
So that's what we feed both of these.
And the reason we use graph replace here
on are our discriminators a is because
it is going to help us
calculate our loss function.
Because we need two of these.
We need,
it's essentially a copy in the computation
graph so that we can do this next
step and you'll see why we
create two discriminators
and then two copies of them.
So then we could then,
uh,
compute the soft plus
function on all four of them.
It's just too discriminators.
But there copies of each.
And if soft plus function is taking the
law of probability of the exponential,
the exponent of our features plus one,
which is an activation function. Okay,
so we, and that's what the soft
plus function I'll tension does.
So we have four a sigmoid is
that we've calculated. Okay.
And then we'll take those
values and we'll use those c.
And this is why we will just add them
together for the original and then the
copy to Compute d code or loss.
And then our encoder loss
for both discriminators.
So we have the laws for
both discriminators and
then we will combine them to
have one big huge discriminator loss.
And we say let's get the average of the
encoder loss minus the average of the
decoder loss. So we take the difference
between the two. What is the difference?
What is the difference here?
Okay,
between what is the original image
and what is the generated image?
Original data distribution generated data,
data distribution, find a difference,
minimize it.
We went there to be no difference.
So it looks very similar
statistically speaking,
to hit to the discriminator. And
that's gonna be our discriminator loss.
Okay? And then we've
defined our loss function,
redefine our discriminators
and then two of our generators.
Now what do we have to do?
We did you find our generator loss
and then our two next generators,
right?
So that's what we're going to do now.
So now we have two more
generators and these same deal.
We've got an inference that
work and are generative network.
And what do we feed it in the
output of the previous generators,
the incoders px and Qsi.
You remember these were right up,
where were they? Right up here.
See Peak px and Qsi. We'd,
if we feed those right into
our next set or coders,
and what does that look like?
That looks like,
that looks like this decoder,
one decode or two.
That's it. We define all six of
them. See how simple that was.
We define all six of them.
Now where was I?
Where was I? Lots of TF
warnings. Warning, warning. Okay,
we've got a generator generators,
we've got our discriminators and now we
want to compute the generator loss we
have are discriminated or loss.
Let's compute the generator loss.
So what do we do? We compute the
sum of squared errors. All right,
so we have generator one,
the compute that computed the generated
the ultimate generated product, right?
That's what rex Z, the reconstruction
of z and reconstruction of Xr.
Those are the ultimate outputs of
our network. The ultimate outputs,
what that mixture of both image data
sets and we want to compute the loss and
that is our predicted
output. The generated output
minus the original Dataset.
So the difference squared and the average.
So the sum of squared errors for
both datasets Casi and then cost x.
And then we compute the advantage loss,
which basically ties into discriminator
loss into the generators loss.
But finding the average of those,
all of the points in that vector,
the average of all those. And we use
that to compute the generator loss,
which is one times the,
uh, advantage loss plus one
times the cost plus one times
the cost of the other image.
So two,
two costs for two image data sets and
that's gonna give us our final generator
loss and I'll answer questions
right after this. Uh,
what after I get done with this
block right here, so then, uh,
we are, we are going to want to
update our, our weights, right?
We want to use our gradients to update
our weights. So that's what we do.
We say we'll use the get collection
method to say within TensorFlow's
computation graph,
I want you to get these values that are,
that have the trainable variable.
And then we define what that variable is,
inference generative discriminator.
And we define those up here.
We define those appear seat,
the scopes.
That's how we call the scopes really
easily. Very, very, very uh, good, uh,
programming syntax.
Syntactic sugar is the, uh,
official term for it. Very,
very cool term. Thank you.
Francoise Chalet for continuously
using that term. Okay, so,
uh, creator of chaos. So the,
so now let's optimize. We've got our,
we've got, we've defined our networks,
we define our loss functions.
Let's optimize,
we'll use Adam for grading
dissent to optimize it,
and then we can minimize both losses,
the minimize the loss for the generator
and then minimize the loss for the
discriminator using the generators
loss and the discriminators loss.
And then what are the values that we
want to update when we can compute our
gradients? What do we want to back
propagate drone network? Well,
these are the,
these are the variables that will,
that will point our point tensor flow
to the memory location of where we these
networks are. Okay, so that's that part.
And let me talk about the training part.
Now we're,
we're done with that part now where
the last part is the training part,
but let me answer some
questions. Let's see. Okay. So
can again be used for audio generation?
Yes.
Gains can be used for audio generation.
That is a novel field and not many
people have attempted that before.
Wave Net was,
it was a great attempt at generating
audio in the style of someone else.
It didn't use a generative
adversarial network though.
So there's a lot of possibility here
that there's so much you could do with
audio generation generating
speech of the style.
Somebody else generating
music and the song.
That's a great one as well. Generative
adversarial networks for music generation.
How cool would that be? Han
Zimmer. Han Zimmer music. Okay,
two more question questions.
Saroj is wrong about textbooks.
Here's the thing.
People have different learning styles.
People have different learning styles
in the age of the Internet where our
attention is split 300 x, right? We pay,
we split our attention.
I saw some statistic recently where it
was like even 10 years ago, our spa,
our attention was split across maybe two
or three different domains across the
entire day, but now it's split across
300 different domains. Twitter, Facebook,
snapchat, life, girlfriend, boyfriend.
This that. There's so many things, right?
So a textbook requires a lot of
attention and a lot of focus,
but we live in an age of instant
gratification. Let's be real. Right?
So we want that instant gratification.
We get that from everywhere else.
We get that from, you know,
mindless entertainment.
We can get that from education
to that's all I'm saying.
But if a textbook works for
you, it works for you. Right.
But I'm just saying that if you are
trying out the textbook for learning and
it's just not clicking, there are other
ways. It's not like the way to learn.
Two more questions. Can we detect
movement in video with Gan? Yes, you can.
Detecting movement is a vague term,
but detecting the direction that
someone is moving. Sure you can.
You can generate,
okay.
Different possibilities of
given some set of frames,
what is going to be the possible next
frames than possible next range and then
and then take those generated frames
across all the generated frames.
Like he moves this way. He was
this way, it moves this way.
Vectorize all those vector vector,
vector vector a vector,
and then compute the distance between
those vectors, perhaps a co-sign, uh,
the coastline distance or you know,
one of, one of the distance functions.
And then,
and then multiply those by some
distance vector and you can see a set of
possible distances and also
get the most likely distance.
That's never been done before.
I just, I just made that, uh,
can you suggest me an NLP books Raj?
Uh,
an LP.
Stanford has a great course.
Michael Collins is a great,
my favorite NLP professor,
he's a professor at Columbia who had now
has an online course on Coursera and a,
a textbook NLP textbook.
Um,
bishop, if you, okay, if you want a
textbook then and uh, bishops, uh,
pattern recognition book is great.
Great section on NLP in there.
One more question. This is fire.
I know it's fire. What is the,
can you show us how to do facial
recognition next? Yeah, I will eventually.
What happens when none of the Ganz
generated images can be classified as a
positive match within one
of the initial data sets?
What,
uh,
what happens if none of the generated
images from again can be classified as a
positive match within one of
the initial data sets? Oh yeah.
So if you're Gan is bad,
like it's not predicting,
well then you tooth, I mean, there's
several things that could be happening,
but it's usually going to be two things.
One,
you got to change your loss function,
try out a different loss function, right?
And your loss function
is just not working.
And it's a very common thing with gans,
although a Wasserstein gans
definitely improve on this. Uh,
so that's one possibility
change a loss function,
but the other is change your Dataset,
add more data and more data. Okay.
So that's it for that.
And so now let's look at the training.
And for training we're going to say,
let's begin our session.
And then inside of our session we're
going to say stable from both data sets.
So from our hex state of saffron,
from Rosita Dataset,
we use our shuffle function to
sample some random values from them.
And then we're going to say,
okay, so for each of those values,
for each of those values,
so we're going to do,
we train this six network
model simultaneously. So
it's happening all at once,
right? It's not like we have some
session and we have another session.
We've announced no, it's one session
and we train them simultaneously.
So we say for,
uh,
for each of those data sets,
let's compute the,
uh,
let's minimize a loss for
both our discriminator.
So this is for a discriminator
feeding hand, both,
both sets of data x andZ ,
and then for our generator feeding
in, again, both sets of data.
And so you might be thinking, well,
shouldn't this be generated or loss?
These three components make up the
generator lost the advantage of loss,
the cost of x and the cost of Z.
Recall up here.
See,
these are the three components.
We could just say January
generator loss as well, but, um,
this is how they implement it in the
paper when in Pi Torch, interestingly,
I mean, but you could say to January
or loss as well. Uh, this isn't it.
There's no reason to do
this specifically. Uh, so
let's, uh, let me just compile
this whole thing and, and, and see,
see what's good. See what happens. Bop,
Bop, Bop, compile, compile, compile,
compile,
and then we get to the end.
Boom training. Just like that
training, training, training.
2% now too.
So he's going to take a while.
So I'm gonna stop it before
my computer gets crazy. Crazy.
Like Charles Barkley. No
Way. Charles. Gnarly. GNARLS
Barkley. I was a great song.
Where was I? Oh, okay. So open this.
Let's look at our results. The results
are going to be saved. We're not,
we're not showing them in the tension
flow graph. They're gonna be saved. And
so check out this,
check out our loss function.
It's like not doing that thing where
it has to go down. It's like going,
it's like going wildly crazy for both
the generator handed discriminator.
So that's just, that's generative
adversarial networks for you.
Although I'm going to talk
about Wasserstein Gans and
show how they improve on
this,
but like Tuck to sell,
right? So we have our true samples
and then we have our inferred samples.
So the inferred samples right here showed
that the combination of the two and so
it just plots that it just creates
those novel red points in from,
from the two initial
data distributions and
yeah, more or less simple
simple idea there. But uh,
that's what the paper was all about.
And remember like when reading papers,
it's really like, let me just, let me just
like, I think this will provide value.
This will provide values to you guys.
So just kind of go for it.
Like how I read papers really quickly.
So the first thing I do is I definitely
read the abstract and the introduction
because those are super simple, right?
It's just, it's just like, you know,
motivations and why they're doing it.
Look at the image.
Usually like 90% of the
time I'll be able to,
you'll be able to Grok what the entire
paper does just by reading the first page.
And a good paper should be like that.
You should be able to understand at a
high level what is happening without
having to look at the entire thing,
right?
That's what the abstract is meant to do.
Okay.
And some people say you read the
abstract at the end rather than at the
beginning. Um, but, and so it depends.
If you are trying to
just get a quick idea, quick and dirty
idea of what the paper is, then I read,
read the abstract at the beginning. Uh,
but some people say read it at the end,
you know, all around. I would
say that's a bad idea. I just, I,
this is how I read papers and
it's worked very well for me.
So I'm going to speak on my own experience
here. So, so that's the first step.
And then so then they'll talk about
their methodologies and bill talk about
usually a diff,
like many different methodologies and
many ideas that they're talking about.
But what you can do is you can go
right to the meat of what it is.
And if you read a lot of papers,
you'll get better at this because right
here in the talking about notation and
architecture, talking about a single
Gann with reconstruction loss,
this is irrelevant to the actual,
um, the, the model that they built.
But if you keep going, you'll
find our proposed model.
This is the actual model. So
you can just, if you want to,
you could skip the rest
and then just read this.
And which is what I did at first. It's
the first pass. I'm like, oh, this is,
this is what they built.
And then we'll talk about their
experiments and they'll have many,
many different steps for the experiment.
And it just kind of like go through it
and you just want to get to the results.
You want to know why did it,
why they made the paper,
what's the model they used and
what are the results and once,
so that's how I look at it.
And our first pass I was going.
So I go all the way down here and I see
the results and see can I see that while
they got state of the art, you
know, in, in these areas. And,
and their conclusion is
like how they would improve.
Once you got that first pass and the
first passion take you like maybe,
I don't know, it takes me,
it took me like 25 minutes,
30 minutes first pass.
Then if you want to then go back and
really like read through all the details
and once you read through all the details,
then look at the code. And there's an,
a good paper always has associated
code. If you, if you are writing papers,
you need to be publishing code.
Okay.
You because you have to help
other people out this stuff.
So that's how I read the paper for
this. Okay. So it's a very new stuff.
It's very new paper and the
next live stream is going to be,
uh,
the last live stream and it will be for,
for this course and it's going to
be a on not deep learning. It's a,
it's a surprise.
Okay,
so let me answer some ending
questions here before we're done.
I'm Hagers all love the show. We have
an eight year old. That's awesome.
That's awesome. Thanks for being
here. Is it the code in the paper?
How do I begin reading source
code from a paper? So source code,
he's usually not in the paper,
but it's on get hub.
So what I do is when I went to find
source code is I will copy and paste the
name of the paper like this into Google
or get hub sometimes get up and it's
going to show up.
If they publish code.
If it doesn't show up on Google's first
page, they haven't published the code.
And so that's, that's, that's not
good. Okay. Two more questions.
Uh,
what's the source of
papers you're mentioning?
A great source for the papers
is archive sanity.
Check this out.
Make that bigger is the
word archive sanity.
Let me paste that right here.
Where is it
checked out? This, there's the link right
here. Archive Sanity and outcome. You can,
you know what it does?
It's a web app that looks at the best
papers for you and it just picks and you
can just,
it just lists them chronologically and
you can look at what the top high papers
are. Great. Great tool. Okay,
so, uh, one more question.
Can we use RNN based architecture
and an adversarial setting,
but realistic text generation tasks mainly
are recurrent net architecture and an
adversarial setting protect
generation tasks. Absolutely.
Absolutely. So first of all,
recurrent nets for text generation.
It's been used before Shakespearian
text, uh, all sorts of texts,
well documented problem,
well defined solutions.
But you could do this
in 10 lines of chaos.
Andre [inaudible] is the king
of this, uh, lots of 10 lines,
snippets on the web to do this.
Very easy to do using LSTM recurrent
networks and an adversarial setting.
I haven't seen it,
but you could,
I would bet you could beat
the state of Vr if you tried.
I would bet you could because
I haven't seen it before.
And overall Gans are just blowing
the state of yard on many,
many different fields so that, that would
be on my bet. Okay. So enough of that.
Let me, uh, let me run me rap.
So I'm going to freestyle, uh,
so someone child to be,
and let me answer one question in the
meantime because it takes a while for that
question to come in. Uh,
one more question. Uh, and,
and it's guys shout out topics for
the freestyle by the way. Okay.
Uh,
can we train a net to
configure a good gan?
That's irrelevant. What was your
uni? I went to Columbia, but look,
don't think like, Oh shit.
You know, he went to Columbia
like he's a, he's a genius.
I can't be like that guys. I
am just like you. I am not some
God. As much as I would like to say that
I am, I'm really not. I'm just like you.
I'm a human. I'm a, I'm a guy. You know,
I'm not some, I'm not, I'm, I don't know.
I don't have a phd or have, you know,
I'm not like sitting there, you know,
I'm just the guy who's really interested
in this stuff and that's all it takes
is an interest. Okay. Uh,
and, and a desire to learn.
Okay. So. All right, so we've got some.
Okay. All right. 10 Sir. All right,
so I'm going to, I'm going to
freestyle about tents. Hit it.
Can we go jazzy?
Tensors it's going to go down in a
second where I want to hear that.
I want to hear the beat drop.
It's all for Tensor, Huh?
It's going to come in a
second. Here we go. 10 Sir.
Here we hear we, we do. We,
I love 10 stores. Try to give back
and give you some a bit lectures.
Every day I come out, it's like
I'm a section leader of a person.
Every time I give it,
you don't even know if I'm leading.
I see these different variables
every single day. I see
you like one, two, three,
four.
Okay.
I think I can define a tense or out of
that my way or use it back to her class
analysis. Okay. There are different
ways of putting this out there. Anyway,
I'm going to talk about demo one, two,
and three. All right. Hey, drop the beat.
Drop it back. Like if you take a
seat, not while I'm rapping, man.
I'm not your enemy.
I see Jupiter notebooks.
Can't you see that's
the only way to do this.
You got a beat on top
whenever you will lease it.
Whenever you show it to the world.
Do you want to make sure it is creasing,
creasing, like paper? You fold it,
you show it to professors like you're
the man. That's it for this. That's it
for the, that's it really. The beat.
The beat didn't drop,
but I just roll with it.
You know the beat in life will
drop when you ask it to. Okay.
So that's it for the live stream.
Thank you everybody for watching.
And uh,
for now I've got to go create the finale.
And don't worry,
I have so much more to come. This, this is
nothing. I'm just getting started. Okay.
So I am just getting started.
Don't be worried like, oh no.
The course is, no, no, no,
no, no. I'm just getting started. Okay,
so for now I've got to write the finale,
so thanks for watching.